hello reject nation Greg Ellis here Greg
Alba here and I am the biggest hater
right here oh no I am guys haven't
watched any reactions with Anita and
Iraq Iraq 'you know she hates rack or a
food and terrible doesn't know I am NOT
a subscriber there's a reason I made
sure to catch up on some racket racket
videos with Anita she's been out of town
for a while but she is the only one I
like John likes raka raka
Anita loves wrecker I like I want to
have racket racket children yeah the
channel I want to have your channel
babies I know you watched only we got a
mansion yeah do you read it stuff yeah
yeah blogs yeah yes so I'm assuming this
is a continuation of a house of racket
thing meaning our biggest hater a lot of
people requested this okay because I was
really scared actually for a minute
there because they hadn't come out with
a lot of content recently and I was like
what happened and I know all this stuff
happening on YouTube I was like they're
definitely going to be affected by their
content you know and so it actually was
worrisome for me for a minute so rock
Iraq I'm glad you're back yeah is that
ease and I can chill out and watch your
content again thank you what are you
doing sorry on TV about 10 minutes among
people singles yeah top 20 pounds now we
don't want to go okay I'm not watching
it's not gonna let your opinion climbing
off the burn the top 70
[Music]
on the weekend
[Laughter]
[Music]
alright hey guys I'm actually off to bed
now cuz I've got a day of work tomorrow
on wolf creek the TV show so sorry guys
really are baby Wolf Creek exit coming
through help as you're sewing North
Creek probably not what I wish you guys
getting into my character because I'm an
extra action okay background extra needs
to be removed from the scene shown
updates we've got the fancy said wow you
guys Lou Sanders awake save Damon's life
so they could have just been happening
not say everyone we've got a pretty big
role with pig farmers two and four he's
on the way back now don't you try to not
see I'm trying to get the character over
here and so you're talking over there's
distracting me as an actor yeah miss you
here I can you can go
[Music]
youngji where i was conscious night yeah
they do be unconscious feet
everyone sampled are some gifts from
japan it's a tradition for everybody
whenever they go to meet somebody to
give them a souvenir what is this c-3po
people feel a little creepy be cognizant
of them you lost a new car share this
video pollute the things I opiates on
the Australian tour leaves learn to play
the didgeridoo for you are you awesome
you're Sam what's next on your list
watching AFL match seeker is dressed
perfectly around your white teeth yes
[Music]
Oh Oh Hungary closes the job here's the
reproduction what bottle since you've
been hanging out all right scoffs a then
bouncing boys going against like this
$250 a [ __ ] ripoff again thanks back
250 ultra tight as a ripple this is
Australia's having quality my quality
teachers show us reduces I got 4/10 I'll
be resolved this one is 10 years old and
those tattoo on my ass check it out what
check out all this dude let me to see
more girls just to get the full scope of
this time you show media person that's a
good to me
wow he looks pretty you doing you well I
can reduce election few people that's up
to you my clothes and cheese and carrot
anyway I've decided this will be a stir
stick down dinner that would put your
sort of an echo
why I had my name so I'm one we all
think you destroyed the thing of it she
it's [ __ ] what about is she just
saying are you trying to fill her in on
the place but I just can't get off this
section I hope [ __ ] from the kitchen
ignoring people yeah well you know the
urn
Wow
oh wow yeah give it no cheating on us
[ __ ] my new video diseases we sorry
gather they are awesome Christ detonated
do some bad things too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow all right sorry I've been reading
the comments related video and I read
every single comment I do I promise you
and we don't have this common right but
it's kid leftist hate common radio which
doesn't offend me at all doesn't set any
of us already for this one what do you
learn to the dress in the first don't
themselves and see the hater influence
influence really
I need actual got to be too perfect can
I am very ridiculous
hey you change the little yeah because I
can love you yeah yeah you said that all
the super you want to try get regular
table sugar [ __ ] oh my god comment did
you prepare dear your mom or anyone that
I go to MA hey maybe Danny fields I want
you to jump the rock record your song
with the comment by portfolio expected
for for students is no employers I can't
see write us or something
this is why because because I people's
feelings and if I wanted leave work like
a kid at a school we could take it
really seriously oh my heart bleeding to
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
I haven't seen every one of their like
hybrids of vlog sketches that they've
been doing I've seen a thing to read
them that this is the fourth watching
that was the funniest what I got to say
I was super awesome and the fact that
they just like went full rocker back at
the end like yes yes my boy it's not as
gory obviously as they used to be it's
not as like they don't break as much
[ __ ] it seems yeah but I feel like you
know they probably had to tone it down
for this new series they probably had to
sit down and we're like look our channel
is [ __ ]
what can we did just upload one video
once a month that is not getting yeah
we're done if we don't change it but
what they have now I think it's
hilarious really I mean it's all rocky
you know it may not be as gorian like
yeah really disturbing like underlying
but I still love it I think it's great
it's cracked me up like I was laughing
hard and we get to get more rock Iraq I
love ya too more the [ __ ] was like once
maybe twice a month a top player now
they're uploading weekly oh man
the best part I really feel like I'm
latching on to more what they're doing
here because every episode is a vlog
with a little bit of sketchy obvious
stuff is practive yet in all improvised
I feel like they're training kind of a
web series yeah you know well because
they're hype they're still sketches that
they're sketch they're not as like
complicated sketches like they used to
do or that they're not going to be
producing is often this is still like a
show is like a continuation show then
living them getting a new house is you
giving the crazy life they live yeah I
think it's almost a spoof of vlogs you
know yeah they're so totally yeah
they're like oh well this is our raka
raka version of the vlog you know and I
think that's a great idea I don't know a
lot of people that are doing that from
what I've seen and this is like perfect
for them so like they really had a good
sit down and talked about where the
direction of channel is going and I like
it a lot I like the real vlog stuff too
like lean on the side of team one being
a part of that they mix that stuff in
and the sketch of him meeting their
biggest hater oh god I always wanted to
do a sketch similar to that I really
couldn't find I'm Bob strikes Mac has a
bit about them media or Internet he has
but I've ever wanted to do it over like
a pirate Emmett is sketch of like
meteors but I love how crazy they got
all rock or a ghost is kicking the [ __ ]
out of him and that was out of stereo
yeah well guys like you can do no wrong
with me sure
Glen wrinkles and I've met the brothers
advocates of you know they said they
like reactions that's what they told me
in a forum a guy named jinx to revolt
there and they said they like it and
I've seen are so subscribe to Iraq Iraq
they do all the hard work amazing you
can subscribe to the real reject do it
all it does is make our number town look
more flashy click that notification bell
even though you already have so many
notifications are probably ignore most
and then hey you know it I need are on
the aeneas target Channel didn't eat it
started to start users and my channel is
technically I need to start gazer
because some lady whoever you are took
my name so I have to be the
I know right but it's okay because you
know I when you start mm-hmm and people
watch me stargazing so it works out well
real life very Kardashian yes yes I am a
Kardashian / Jenner
I didn't want my popularity to be based
on my family history okay so I had to
like separate my tears from this are I
love you fam I love you Kardashians
Robert